okay first of all hi uh first of all
miranda i have to ask you with the
cussing challenge now that it's blown up
on tick tock
and it's it's really fun josh peck lizzo
jojo siwa all doing it do you have a
favorite has one just made you chuckle
to yourself
um i think josh pecks was probably my
favorite because he's my friend and i
thought it was super fun
um yeah i thought joe jonas the one that
he did was funny
all of them are funny it's just like so
crazy i never thought that uh that would
happen
what has been your reaction to it are
you like annoyed of it or at this point
or are you still entertained by this
um i'm just totally entertained by it
[Laughter]
jerry after all these years working
together um do you feel like you're a
big brother to miranda in real life like
do you guys have that like brother or
sister
yeah
yeah
yeah
if i could share the conversations
miranda and i are very close and uh and
we're we're
fair i
i tease her
probably more mercilessly in real life
than on the show
but it's all it's all in good fun and we
we poke fun at each other and uh
but also we have our real sibling we
give each other advice um
i give her good advice she gives me real
trash advice
[Laughter]
yeah but yeah that's my life
i never take it but it's good
she never takes it she knows she should
but she will not do it
uh miranda everyone is so excited about
you reuniting with josh this season um
what was it like being back together on
set with him
it was awesome um you know i met him
when i was eight years old when i was on
drake and josh that was my first acting
job ever i met jerry during that too and
um it was just so fun getting to be back
on set with him and now that he's
married i'm actually really close with
his wife paige um and i got to hang out
with his son recently which was so fun
like getting to really like hang out
with him for the first time he's like
three um
so yeah it was just it was awesome
getting to have him on the show and he
plays my character carly's manager and
he's in multiple episodes throughout the
season so it was a dream come true yeah
i know carly's trying to win the
internet back like she's just dealing
with haters that can be rough how have
you learned to deal with those like
internet trolls over time
um for me i think the thing that's
helped me most is just like trying to
ignore it because yeah i have a bad
tendency of like if i read comments
there could be like 100 really nice
comments and i'll focus in on the one
mean one or i'll remember that one
instead of all that
and i feel like um there's definitely an
episode that kind of touches on that
this season with carly even though it's
like in a light fun way um just about
how like so many influencers they have
like these really positive fun like
upbeat images to withhold and then it's
like it's hard sometimes when people um
are always judging you and like writing
stuff about you online so yeah fun to do
an episode about that yeah miranda have
you tried my tactic of just being
universally beloved
i need to try it makes it real easy it's
just smooth sailing
oh my god jerry we saw a preview of
rachel bloom being on the show and she's
hilarious obviously love her um what can
you tell us about her role in the series
and i'm assuming it was a blast having
her yeah she's super fun and funny um
i don't know what i'm allowed to say i
know
you know
you know
there's some there's some heat there's
some romance
oh
and
carly and harper
try and make over spencer to be more
like the type of dudes that rachel
bloom's character plays
goes for
um
and uh it just doesn't go well
interesting
interesting okay
spencer's i think a little bit more into
her than she's into him
got you okay
okay well thank you guys oh my god it's
time okay thank you guys so much for
your time it was so nice to talk to you
guys nice to meet you thank you
thank you nice to meet you bye
you